[Música]
[Aplausos]
tô aqui pra falar com vocês sobre minha
trajetória como eu gosto de colocar o
meu mapa do tesouro e assim uma palestra
bem chata se fosse o diabo enfim né mas
não é tão fácil assim mais ou menos isso
mas deixa para o final
a minha trajetória eu acho que é
interessante porque eu sou um grande
sonhador
eu sou uma pessoa que acredita que nada
na vida é impossível
desde muito pequena eu sempre falei pra
todo mundo que eu queria ser piloto de
avião
consultórios médico novo ano na escola é
um novo amigo que você conhece sempre
apresentava com isso só tinha uma
resposta a esse menino é maluco nunca
vai ser piloto de franca do interior não
conhece ninguém mas eu não esqueci
sempre queria ser piloto
como eu era muito novo eu comecei com o
sport já que era um sonho um pouco mais
próximo de mim então eu tentei basquete
futebol tênis acredito como muitos
jovens muitos meninos como eu sou um
sonhador
eu queria um esporte que fosse realmente
desafiador
então eu escolhi o tênis que foi e seria
o que me ajudaria na minha trajetória
começando desde muito pequeno
foi apenas uma brincadeira até os 13
anos quando eu resolvi dar um passo
maior e tentar começar minha carreira de
fato nos estados unidos
me mudei para lá tive a oportunidade de
treinar tênis o dia todo e estuda no
tempo que sobrava e não foi tão fácil
primeiro pela mudança de país
convivência com gente de tudo quanto é
lugar do mundo e os esse sonho terminou
quando eu vi que aquilo não era
realmente pra mim mas tanto nos estados
unidos eu tive a oportunidade de
resgatar aquele sonho anterior de voar
lá não tem limite ou idade mínima
para se começar então com 15 anos eu
comecei o meu treinamento com 16 anos eu
vá sozinho
com 17 anos eu já tinha minha primeira
habilitação que foi adquirida no dia do
meu aniversário que era o primeiro dia
que eu podia até ela e com 18 anos eu já
era instrutor de aula pra gente do mundo
inteiro para aprender como voar nesse
ponto a gente está mais ou menos em 2008
que foi quando a crise econômica atingiu
o mundo todo mas principalmente os
estados unidos ea minha carreira que
tinha acabado de começar
estava quase parando já que a economia
realmente desabasteceu todo mundo de
meios de correr atrás desse sonho também
foi onde eu dei mais um passo
eu retornei para o brasil onde naquela
época ainda a economia estava melhor e
tive a oportunidade de ser empregado
para uma grande companhia aérea isso com
19 anos com 21 já fazia vôos
internacionais e o gráfico da minha
carreira era mais ou menos assim ele
começou devagarzinho de um pouquinho
maior
e de repente subiu de uma vez dois anos
depois esse gráfico se transformou um
pouco
ele começou a ficar um pouco mais linear
uma estabilidade como eu subi muito
rápido eu alcancei aquela aquela posição
que muita gente alcançaria muito tarde
na na carreira e eu comecei a ver que eu
iria conseguir tudo aquilo que eu queria
só tinha que esperar então era só sentar
relaxar e aproveitar a viagem que tudo
que eu sonhava e alcançar já era piloto
já vivi o que eu queria fazer
até que foi diagnosticado com diabetes
tipo 1 não conhecia nada sobre essa
doença sobre essa condição de vida a não
ser uma coisa eu teria que tomar
insulina insulina e piloto não combino e
minha carreira tinha acabado mais um
passo de são paulo onde eu executava
minha profissão para franca cidade onde
nós estamos cidade onde eu nasci onde a
minha família mora
esse diagnóstico exigia para mim
dança de vida eu teria que me adaptar a
uma situação nova a uma rotina de
medicamentos visitas a médicos
uma nutrição completamente diferente do
que estava habituado a isso tudo até que
seria fácil mas na minha cabeça eu
estava dentro de um labirinto que seria
de mim agora
desde muito jovem falando que quer ser
piloto de avião agora não sei mais quem
eu sou
foi aí que eu comecei a trabalhar com o
calçado pela estrutura que a minha
família tinha foi a oportunidade que eu
tive de colocar o pé no chão e tentar
entender o que eu seria daqui pra frente
continuava dentro do labirinto
pessoalmente
foi aí que eu conheci uma frase que
serve pra mim até hoje
toda vez que você tiver em um labirinto
para e sinto o cheiro das flores
elas vão te guiar o caminho de fora
perceba tudo que está o teu redor
aquilo pra mim naquele momento significa
significava encontrar uma nova paixão
eu precisava achar alguma coisa que
fosse maior do que eu
maior do que a rotina das 8 às cinco da
tarde trabalhador me com 6 trabalhador
me comer eu precisava de alguma coisa
maior
eu tentei várias coisas sonhando sempre
achei que direito seria um caminho legal
para mim seguir à final de contas é uma
profissão que eu acredito que explica
como entender o mundo todo
donde a um dia de faculdade nunca mais
voltei pensei em ficar na frente do
teclado dia todo seja como escritor
programador alguma coisa que me
colocasse com computação diariamente
quer uma atividade que eu gostava muito
também não foi pra frente
fiquei no calçado mas como eu já falei
pra vocês eu sou um sonhador e eu não
queria ficar parado naquilo só no
momento eu pensei que a minha saúde era
mais importante que eu precisava trocar
todos esses termos de aviação pelos
novos de diabetes e precisava encarar
com o mesmo profissionalismo com a mesma
dedicação esse novo desafio
a saúde é mais importante
eu vou parar sentir o cheiro das flores
e tentar me adaptar a minha nova
situação eu procurei alguma maneira de
melhorar minha saúde
bem simples
me tornei vegetariano mudando a minha
dieta abolir o consumo de qualquer tipo
de carne de uma só vez
não tirei o peso ou a carne vermelha
primeiro e continuei com o peixe não um
dia parei com tudo isso trouxe uma
grande melhora pra minha vida eu estava
pronto para dar o próximo passo
eu me tornei vegano pegando além da
alimentação ele a bola o insumo de
origem animal de todo o seu consumo
sapato cento carteira o banco de carro
enfim organismo exige respeito absoluto
com toda a forma de vida até o mel de
abelha
o trabalho com o sapato e agora que eu
vou usar o que eu vou fazer no meu dia a
dia
voltei para o lugar que eu conheço bem
aquele labirinto
já sei o que fazer eu vou parar e sentiu
o cheiro das flores e vou tentar fazer
com esses limões uma boa limonada
respeito absoluto com toda forma de vida
eu vou fazer um calçado pra mim que
outros com certeza vão gostar também
montei uma marca de sapatos veganos em
seis meses depois a gente monta o nossa
própria fábrica que hoje continua sendo
a única fábrica 100% vegana do mundo
esse é meu mapa do tesouro só faltando
uma coisinha o x
eu saí da volta ao mundo
seguindo o meu sonho e retornei para o
mesmo lugar onde estava meu verdadeiro
tesouro
então o que eu tenho pra compartilhar
com vocês é pra todo mundo se lembrar
quando você tiver algum problema estiver
dentro de um abrindo parecendo o cheiro
das flores na solução vai estar o teu
redor
não precisa ir longe uma pedra no seu
caminho pode se tornar o seu grande
aliado o que está ao seu redor pode
transformar a sua vida e muitas vezes
vai verdadeiramente nós somos o
resultado de nossas experiências não
saia viva experimente r acerte
esse é o mapa do tesouro pode estar
muito mais perto do que você imagina
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]